Charley Steiner the Dodgers radio
play-by-play broadcaster you got game on
Braves tomorrow and Charlie joins us now
hi Charlie how are you good to visit
with you we just figured it right yeah
this is the time of year we work for
well we had a Rick Sutcliffe on last
hour and I said is there any you know
you surprised that plate and Kershaw is
not you know going game on and he said
no because he's not the ace of the staff
anymore what do you make of that
I don't know that I would go that far
but down the stretch Ria's been great
Kershaw has kind of scuffled down the
stretch a couple of other things that
play one Ryu could pitch on regular rest
and so too can Kershaw who if need-be
can pitch in Game five so I don't think
this is a major alteration as much as it
is a tweak but reeve down the stretch is
NDRF under - he's been great yeah well
how would you handicap the National
League playoffs because the Braves feel
like an unknown Milwaukee it still feels
like have they proven themselves as the
team to beat throw the Dodgers in there
and the Rockies eliminating the Cubs so
feels like it's wide open is it probably
you know the Dodgers have been there and
done that
Milwaukee seems to me again from afar we
haven't seen him in a long time there's
a team that seems to have the juju this
year everything seemed to be going right
their bullpen is unconscious they've got
the best player in the league this year
and Yelich I mean it just seems to be
falling into place of course that can
change two or three games the Rockies
and Dodgers they know one another pretty
well the Dodgers I think are a little
bit better than they are either for no
other reason
familiarity breeding contempt and the
Dodgers won 13 out of 20 from them so I
think as of whatever time it is in the
morning October the 3rd the Dodgers and
the Brewers would be the most likely
combatants and I feel kind of badly in a
way for Colorado just knowing what
happened last year in the postseason
when the cub
at Nationals beat the hell out of water
another in the Cubs rotation was a mess
an Arizona had the same issue in the
first round of the playoffs with
Colorado and so their rotation was a
mess
so the Rockies are going to have a hard
time all things being equal against
Milwaukee but they don't know who's
going to be pitching tomorrow much less
two three days down the road it's going
to be a game today a game deal yasiel
Puig in the post National League West
celebration in locker room said that
he'd guarantee they were gonna win the
World Series I'm curious how other
Dodger players view yasiel Puig and him
saying something like this it's been
tweaked and that's what you get you have
this unbelievable talent who kind of
toddles to the beat of his own beats
headset so he says stuff and this I
think tweak being tweaked but again Joe
Namath guaranteed a Super Bowl but that
didn't work out too badly either yeah
but he was the star of the team I don't
know but you know Puig is not what I
think we thought he was going to be I
think he's a good player I think he's
you know and he got hot at a great time
for them I just didn't know if they kind
of look at him the way you described him
is you know that's just him he's just
funny and goofy and you know we let him
say what he wants saying it's not like
Clayton Kershaw saying I guarantee this
right when Kershaw doesn't go down that
path nor does he live that see the life
through his eyes as Puig does you know
again Regas is supreme talent and I
still think he is going to get better as
a player he is right now in a big
situation he's dangerous and if I'm the
other team I'm not sure I want to mess
with him but then again that's one of
the things that Dodgers have going for
them this incredible depth but to your
point I think it's fleet being Puig and
they just move on and I don't think
baseball is given to the headlines and
locker room stuff that it once was and
after all it wasn't MLB just last night
promoting let the players play and be
exuberant and all of that
Dave Roberts was going to get fired
earlier in this season wasn't
oh I don't know about that let me tell
you about Dave Roberts and he's been a
good friend of mine going back before he
stole the bass in 2004 he's smart
grounded he's a great communicator and
he was I was thinking about this the
other day he has managed to keep a lot
of egos in check with the platooning
that has gone on and I'm remembering
back to the days when I was doing the
Yankees you know that that was a room
filled with egos at Joe Torre could kind
of leave alone and self police and he
also had Don Zimmer there and most
importantly he had as the shop steward
Derek Jeter here this was essentially a
Dave Roberts operation and when they
were going bad he hung in there in fact
I think April 29th or 10 games under 500
whatever it was he said we're still the
best team we're going to win they were
and they did so I think this is his
third year he's gone to the postseason
each of the three years I think this by
far was his most challenging and his
best year as a manager yeah I like him I
he's one of my favorite interviews he's
interesting he's got perspective he'll
give you an opinion and and I appreciate
that in this business but you know I and
maybe saying he was gonna be fired there
were certainly they were circling you
know the vultures were circling when
you're 10 games under 500 with that kind
of payroll and I think that you know
there was a little bit of pressure there
or at least it felt like there was
pressure applied you know that 10 game
under 500 things again put that that's
the macro the micro was they missed
Justin Turner probably their best
everyday player for the first 40 games
of the year and it really wasn't until
about the middle of June when the team
started to heat up and and Turner was
back every day that broken hand wrist
you know naturally hit the last day of
spring training miss 40 games that's
when the Dodgers got off to the slow
start but after his return I'm not
putting it all on one guy suddenly you
put maybe their best hitter
right into the middle of the lineup
where it didn't exist for the first two
months that was a big difference also
you know when you look at this team I
don't know how much drama you have or
what is considered drama because you
used to do play-by-play for the Yankees
where it felt like if there wasn't drama
what is your favorite story if you were
going to encapsulate what it was all
about when you were there broadcast in
the Yankees what you saw what you heard
do you have a favorite story you know it
may have actually come before I did the
play-by-play back in the Bronx Zoo years
when when Greg nettles said
matter-of-factly about Sparky Lyle he's
gone from sy young to sayonara when when
goose Gossage in a hissy fit about
George Steinbrenner take it upstairs to
the fat man and you know you're there in
the middle of all of this stuff and you
say thank you God
this is right there's none of that
anymore but it's oh it's you know that
that's Broadway here it's Hollywood so
it's not quite as manic and bizarre as
it was 30 35 years ago if you were doing
the pecking order or the totem pole in
Los Angeles for sports teams we're right
now where are the Lakers
where are the Dodgers and where are the
Rams because it is October 3rd and we're
heading into perhaps another World
Series gotta put the Dodgers first the
Rams are moving up and down the stretch
they come and the Lakers with the
arrival of LeBron takes that to I think
more of an entertainment level rather
than a competitive level
the Rams or the NFL but at the end of
the day it's the Dodgers and the Dodgers
and they're in first place and they won
the division six consecutive years and
have as good a chance as anybody to go
to the World Series again
we were just showing on the live look in
for people watching on TV when you were
doing SportsCenter when Carl Lewis sang
the anthem and you you gave us Francis
Scott off-key for Carl Lewis and you
couldn't you were famous for not being
able to hold it together Charlie and I
mean that as a compliment
no and I take it as one because how else
was I going to take it at that point I
was relatively new to television and
that moment was just where I totally
lost it but in some way it was very
liberating because if I laughed my ass
off like that and still had a job the
next day maybe I could actually make it
because when I came up from you know we
were downstairs the studio then we went
upstairs to that big old bullpen area
room passing for a news room everybody's
laughing and I thought well okay maybe I
did survive this thing after all I think
you guys ran it at 11 o'clock that night
too and and every anniversary Carl and I
are on television together and in the
100th anniversary of ESPN he and I but
despite being phosphorous will be dates
he doesn't get our fascination with it I
did an interview with him and and his
brother told me he was I I don't know
why I still bring that up thank you you
know IIIi in many ways I do feel badly
about it because he was one of the great
seminal athlean of the 20th century and
sadly as many people if not more
remember his anthem which was
certifiably awful and you know and I'm
the sidecar on this this runaway
motorcycle that they remember him as
much for that is all the great stuff
that he did as an Olympian so I I feel
badly in some in some degree but you
know it was live what are you gonna do
yeah I know it wasn't that it it wasn't
that it wasn't not funny and to see
Derrick Coleman pulling his warm-ups
over his mouth so we couldn't see him
laughing you know
that morning the morning that we decided
to run that I was driving into work and
I listened to WFAN and they had like 10
seconds of the anthem and you least have
those morning meetings and we'd sit
around and what stories ideas I said you
know I heard something on the radio this
morning Carl Lewis did the anthem it
wasn't really very good maybe we have it
well they got it and the rest sadly is
history it was hysterical oh man and
just to see and I guess I lost it
probably twelve it was funny I know
we're supposed to be you know have
decorum and we're supposed to be you
know we're we're gonna we're gonna keep
our dignity here we're not gonna show
our emotions and all of a sudden you
just start laughing you were doing what
we did behind the scenes off-camera or
we wanted to do and then finally you did
it and you're like it's okay it's all it
it's all right to say hey my bad or I
made a mistake on this highlight or
whatever it is it was just you're right
yeah you took off the Hans device not
intentionally just you know much like
what we did back then we did stuff and
all of a sudden like hey that works or
hey that didn't work let's not do that
anymore so suddenly I lose it and it's
like it's okay we're still on the air
we'll be back tomorrow and then you know
that Tonya Harding comes along and Mitch
blood green and all he's a bird Terry
wood all of these things that I found
particularly humorous
I was I was freed of the shackles of
trying to bite my lower lip
do you ever cross paths with Mike Tyson
anyone yes and we're okay there was a
time that we weren't I haven't seen him
in the last year or two but one day he
said we came over to I'm thinking this
is not going to end well and he gives me
a big hug and he said nice to see you
and he just said you know in retrospect
you were always fair he at
that time had a difficulty of trying to
negotiate the path between what he
perceived as friendship and what my job
was to cover him so he always felt that
I should be defending him and I said no
it doesn't work that way and it took a
long time for him to finally come to
terms with that and realize it Charlie
have fun in the postseason always great
to catch up with you and thanks for
joining us
anytime Dan thank you that's Charlie
Steiner
Dodgers radio play-by-play voice for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]